qué cree usted que sigue para el rey y
además la relación bien importante con
la
comowealth que integran 52 países
entiendo y además con la posibilidad de
que algunas territorios en el Caribe
busquen la posibilidad de un referendo
para convertirse en repúblicas Bueno
pues la monarquía en el Reino Unido como
ya lo hemos visto a lo largo de esta
transmisión tiene unos vínculos
políticos y económicos muy importantes
con la nación y como lo manifestaba
antes el Rey Carlos III ha hablado y
sigue proclamando la idea de una mayor
cercanía con el pueblo y de un mejor
entendimiento de sus problemas y sus
dificultades en términos políticos el
rey tiene que contribuir en forma
decisiva
primero que todo al mantenimiento del
Reino Unido con las voces que se han
producido en los últimos años de
independencia de Escocia los movimientos
unionistas en Irlanda del Norte
también ciertas disidencias en gales la
posibilidad de disolución del Reino
Unido es algo sobre lo cual hay muchos
comentaristas y hay muchas voces O sea
que aquí Unido con los partidos
políticos con las fuerzas sociales del
país el Rey Carlos III tendrá un trabajo
muy importante que hacer por el otro
lado lo que se llama la mancomunidad
británica el commonwell es una Unión
económica y política que ha sido de una
gran importancia en la vida del Reino
Unido y de los que fueron sus dominios y
Naciones que continúan
íntimamente ligadas culturalmente
económicamente
54 países forman parte de esta
mancomunidad y Hoy día hay 14 países en
los cuales todavía
el soberano
del Reino Unido es el jefe de estado
entre ellos se cuentan países tan
importantes como Australia como Nueva
Zelanda como Canadá y algunas de las
Islas británicas como el estilo de Santa
Lucía y Jamaica kitsan nieves en fin en
muchos de estos países Ya hay unas
encuestas recientes que muestran que hay
una proclividad hacia la convertir estos
países en repúblicas es decir prescindir
del monarca británico como su jefe de
estado
el Rey Carlos III ha viajado
intensamente él ha sido un gran viajero
a todos estos países mantiene una gran
relación con los países de la comunidad
y yo estoy seguro que esa será una de
sus primeras tareas una mayor
aproximación un mayor entendimiento de
los problemas y al final del día ver
cómo evoluciona la política de los
países en términos a sus autonomías y a
sus independencias